my sense is in that kind of situation we
should it there on the side of Liberty
including err on the side of Liberty of
self-defense hi I'm Ted baliker with
Reason TV and today I'll be sitting down
with Eugene Bullock Bullock is the Gary
T Schwartz professor of law at the UCLA
School of Law he's also the founder and
co-author of the popular legal blog the
Falak conspiracy when it comes to
threats to free speech do you see them
coming these days mostly from the left
or from the right well there are some
from each guide you look at the polls it
turns out that liberals and
conservatives Democrat and Republicans
have pretty much the same percentages
supporting speech and supporting
restriction regardless of of what their
politics are so in fact the sense that
say races speech most Democrats most
liberals want to suppress it most
Republicans a one to protected and
there's some big gulf between them the
polls just don't bear that out when it
comes to the rank and file now it does
turn out though that if you look not at
the voters or the justices but at the
backers of the intellectual academic and
institutional backers of some
restrictions there is something of a
liberal conservative divide for example
campus speech codes seem to be mostly
backed by a combination of mostly
liberal at university administrators and
professors on the other hand they're
also attempts to restrict speech from
the right and that that's both speech
for example it's sexually themed but
even beyond that generally speaking it's
more conservatives and liberals who are
in favor of firing government employees
or at least giving the government the
right broad right to fire government
pleas for their speech including for
whistleblowing speech at the like should
we think that the First Amendment would
you say that it enjoys more popular
support and more real-world protection
than other amendments in the Bill of
Rights it's very hard to compare the
relative force of various kinds of
constitutional amendments in part
because they're written in different
ways so the fourth amendment or example
many people say well the fourth
amendment is not being protected enough
but the fourth amendment restricts not
searches and seizures it restricts
unreasonable search as usual so is does
the Fourth Amendment is it being
enforced less strictly than the First
Amendment well it's hard to say it may
be just because it's written
strictly that it ends up often
authorizing a lot of government action
whereas in the First Amendment context
generally speaking government action
restricting speech is as viewed much
more skeptically if you have to choose
one or two of the biggest threats to
free speech free expression these days
what would it be one is this notion of a
hostile environment harassment and that
is the notion that speech people
expressing their views people making
jokes sometimes people posting sexually
say material sometimes people making
political statements religious
proselytizing can become legally
punishable discrimination simply because
it is and I'm quoting here there's a
very vague language of the law severe or
pervasive enough to degrade a hostile
abusive or offensive environment based
on race religion sex sexual orientation
and the like and this could be an
employment in education and public
accommodations there is the the
limitation that it's only actionable
that way only lead to a lawsuit if they
creates a hostile environment for a
reasonable person but it's not basically
very vague and very broad standard so
it's become essentially a nationwide
speech code for America's workplaces and
not just imposed by the private property
owners who run the workplaces there of
course are entitled to restrict speech
on their property and by their employees
but rather it's imposed by the
government that employers are being
coerced into suppressing certain times
of speech by fear of massive liability
I'll give you a chance to take a set
reason TV to task we have this this
series we call nanny of the month one
month we singled out the Alabama Supreme
Court for upholding a state ban on
selling sex toys you said that that was
improper we shouldn't have tarred the
Alabama Supreme Court as being nannies
why is that it's the job of legislators
to impose only those legal rules that
are genuinely necessary to protect
individual liberty or some really very
very important social social interests
but that's not the job of judges the job
of judges is to follow the law and to
enforce the law and it's far from clear
to me that the Alabama Constitution the
US Constitution protects the right to
have sex toys one could argue that it
should but it's perfectly reasonable for
a court to say look there's nothing in
our Constitution that interferes with
legislative judgment here
could be a silly law it could be an
illiberal law it could be a nanny law
but it's not our job to act essentially
as protectors against the nannies the
protectors against the nannies should be
other legislators should be the voters
and the if you don't like the nannies in
the legislature vote them out so by
definition judges can't be nannies so I
think judges could be nannies when it
comes to judges creating legal rules and
historically in the American and
anglo-american legal system many
basically Google's a contract of
property law of tort law even
historically criminal law I have been
created by judges the earliest
restrictions actually on private sexual
conduct were actually judge made rules
likewise a lot of tort law rules are
judge made rules so I think judges could
be nannies that they set up tort law
rules that are unduly paternalistic for
example that end up protecting people so
much from ordinary hazards that they
essentially drive the useful products
that people should have the choice to
use and drive them off the market let's
talk about gun control in a post heller
world what's the main takeaway of the
District of Columbia vs. Heller Supreme
Court decision Supreme Court held in DC
versus Heller that the Second Amendment
secures among other things an individual
right to keep and bear arms including
handguns in self-defense so what I think
is going to be happening under the
second moment what we've seen happening
and will continue to happen even if the
Supreme Court holds in the coming now
Chicago case is that the right to keep
and bear arms applies to state and local
governments is if there's a total gun
ban that will be struck down total
handgun ban that'll be struck down
possibly some other laws may be total
bans on carrying guns that's an open
question whether those would be upheld
or not maybe bands on possessing guns in
public housing complexes occasionally
you have such some such laws those might
be struck down but bans and so-called
assault weapons the various waiting
period laws licensing registration laws
I think courts are going to say those
are permissible regulations rather than
total prohibitions let's talk about how
media coverage of gun incidents affects
public perception if there's a gun
incident almost by definition if you see
it on the 11 o'clock news it's because
some
shot someone with a gun but most actual
gun incidents you can imagine a
perpetrator breaking into your house you
merely brandished the gun you don't fire
it the guy runs away so media coverage
of guns is skewed in various ways one
way is my sense is that at least in many
media outlets the people who write about
them and will cover them are actually
someone anti-god and as a result the
coverage ends up being anti-god there's
also just the bias that the that it's
news if if a gun is used in a way that
is easily noticeable it's not news if a
gun is used the way that most guns are
used which is somebody breaks into some
somebody else's home the homeowners say
takes out a shotgun pumps the shotgun
the burglar here is that familiar
familiar sound and runs away that's a
very common and useful use of a gun it's
not going to make the news so those are
two reasons why news coverage is biased
I think against gun rights the same time
entertainment I think is biased whether
intentionally or not in favor of guns
guns are glamorous things in television
programs and in movies my sense is also
that people who use guns and movies use
them much more successfully than guns
are actually used in real life the fact
is that especially under combat
conditions it's very hard to hit
somebody the first time around I don't
think the television and movies
accurately capture that fact as a result
they make guns seem more effective than
they actually are in many respects and
as I said they seem glamorous do you
generally speaking agree with that more
guns less crime thesis I think it's very
hard to tell what the precise effects
are of allowing more law-abiding
citizens to get carry concealed carry
licenses it is pretty clear that the
overwhelming majority of people who get
concealed carry licenses use their guns
responsibly we have shifted from an
environment where about ten states
allowed every law-abiding adult to get a
concealed carry or nearly every
law-abiding adult to get a concealed
concealed carry license to a situation
we have 40 states that allow nearly
every adult to get a concealed carry
license and we have not seen any massive
increase in either crime generally or in
traffic shootings or crimes of passion
what have you so the fears of the gun
control proponents have certainly not
materialized on the other hand whether
there is a modest increase very small
but measurable increase in crimes as a
result whether there's a small but
measurable decrease in violent crime as
a result very hard to tell there are
competing arguments competing data sets
of competing models I think that's
something that there needs to be more
research on but it is pretty clear that
it has not had massive effects one way
or the other
my sense is in that kind of situation we
should add err on the side of Liberty
including our own side of Liberty or
self-defense
you